so during the depths of the pandemic we
all had to adjust from working for
working at home life is opened up of
course but some business owners have
discovered home offices aren't all bad
yeah still some work is a little bit
better when you can collaborate in
person with other people and that's
where that growing co-op model really
fits in mary jane belly is live in the
southwest valley with a new space that
really encourages that hybrid work
environment mayor dane i'm on board with
this but i just can't figure out how to
make it work for us
yeah well john and heather i think a lot
of people have discovered you know
remote work and even in a co-working
space really makes it that much better
because not only are you working with
other people from different fields but
you do get that space to yourself and
we're in the second co-op space i have
dana bergeron she's the owner of the
coop and dana thank you so much for
joining us early this morning now
between the first building that you had
open it's been five years and as we know
this isn't a normal office space i mean
look how beautiful just one of these
offices are right now so can you talk to
us a little bit about what a co-working
space is for those who don't know sure
and thank you so much for being here and
happy co-working month
so
a co-working space is a shared workspace
with flexible work options and focusing
on community and collaboration so
we are a larger workspace with shared
amenities allowing businesses big and
small to have remote workers test the
waters
starting up a new business and basically
working the way that you want to
in a shared workspace and as we know
during covet i mean everything was shut
down so you probably really saw that
increase pick up especially since people
saw hey i like working from home or
working remotely exactly and we're happy
to be a platform for people to give them
the options of working the way that they
want to work so the
adage of co-working is work for yourself
not by yourself so we do have
entrepreneurs solopreneurs small
companies and we also have remote
workers when their offices closed
they were forced to work from home so we
do give people the option of getting
into a work space and using it the way
that they want to oh dana thank you so
much definitely see more of these office
spaces opening up too reporting live
mary jane ballisa live local now
mary jane billy is alive in the
southwest valley at a new space to
encourage that hybrid work
mary jane tell us all about it good
morning
yeah john and heather good morning to
you we're in the second location of the
coop on russell and decatur in the
classroom portion of the building this
space is huge perfect enough for
lectures and seminars really a great way
to gather people in your office into one
space i'm here joined early this morning
with dr siddhkarana with nevada mental
health and thank you so much doctor for
waking up with us so early as we talked
about this is a great way for people who
feel isolated to come together and feel
like they belong correct absolutely that
is true first if i may take a minute
back and say we were forced to do remote
work and with the remote work what you
miss is the sense of embodied presence
just like right now we are here
in the in the zoom screens you just
focus on the face and in the in-person
interactions you can have the nonverbal
cues the whole body language
a sense of presence of the other person
when you don't have that you miss the
organic social interactions
with a place like this a co-working
space inherently that's what it promotes
and it it increases the sense of
connectivity people feel connected to
each other and when we didn't have that
there was a lot of isolation people
didn't have the drive or the motivation
to leave their home to get to work and
there was a lot of isolation and you
know all about that too because not only
do you meet with patients in person but
even
zoom or remote work as well i do i have
actually been doing telehealth for the
last 14 years i do hybrid work i do
patients i see patients in person and i
see patients who are telehealth and and
it works but it doesn't work for all
that's right so this is a great way to
have that hybrid connection and also
choose to work remotely as well thank
you so much dr karana reporting live
mary jane vallieza live local now